people don't go to the doctor unless
they have a symptom right I mean you
never really go to prevent a problem or
get healthy it's after you have probably
multiple symptoms and so a symptom is
your body's way of telling you there's a
problem so these communications back
from your body are valuable but the
problem is especially if we're talking
about the kidney is most of the time
there is no sign or symptom that you
have a kidney problem so when we talk
about early kidney disease or even early
liver disease there is no symptoms
whatsoever unless you do a urine test
where you find protein or the filtration
of the kidney is being interrupted you
don't really know if you have a problem
but as the kidney progresses and gets
worse when it goes through the different
stages stages one two three four and
then eventually five there are
indicators or symptoms that you need to
know about and I'm going to cover those
right now but for a lot of people they
actually have a kidney problem and they
don't even know it okay so let's go
through these symptoms just to increase
your awareness so that way you can do
something about it the first one is
fatigue easily okay you get weak and
tired very easily I mean you can get
tired with exercise but I'm talking
about normal daily activities number two
is periorbital edema puffy eyes that
means your kidneys are backing up with
fluid it's backing up through the
lymphatics and it's showing up in the
eyes boy you know when I'm out in public
sometimes I'll see people with that and
I'm really tempted to come up to them
and mention that but I I have to
withhold myself but once you know the
look you'd be surprised how many people
have that and don't even realize what it
is I guess the more I think about it I
think it'd be kind of weird going up to
someone and say have you ever been
checked for periorbital edema they might
look at you kind of funny
all right number three edema or swelling
in your lower legs or your feet this has
to do with the kidneys losing protein
and anytime there's a protein imbalance
in the body you're going to retain fluid
but around your cells and because
gravity pulls things down you're going
to see this in the lower ankles and the
feet in fact when you press into your
ankles you'll see that pitting edema
which is pretty wild to know that I had
pitting edema years ago in my early 30s
I remember pressing into my ankle
looking at it going
what the heck is going on with that now
I don't have any pitting edema back then
I did the next one on the list is you're
urinating at night more than during the
day now that can come from diabetes or
pre-diabetes or insulin resistance which
a lot of people have and don't even know
they have it is one of the main causes
of a kidney problem so that's in the
background and just as a side note I did
a video on
frequent urination especially at night
and there are so many people that
experienced great results in getting rid
of that condition by changing their diet
and I will put that video down below now
the next one is foamy urine kind of like
if you just someone poured a glass of
beer right you see that foam at the top
that is protein in the urine all right
next one is high blood pressure now high
blood pressure can come from several
things it can come from a nutritional
problem it can come from diabetes it can
come from a heart problem and it can
come directly from a kidney problem
because there's kidney damage all right
the next one is you feel nauseous
especially in the morning when you wake
up sometimes to the point where you want
to vomit now that probably is going to
happen a little bit later in the stages
of kidney disease but you're going to
notice that in the morning you just you
feel kind of sick and that is because
all night all this toxic waste is being
building up in the body body and those
toxins haven't been released yet so
they're kind of backing up into the
system all right and then the next one
is the metallic taste in your mouth what
is that that is basically toxins backing
up to your system and it's coming up to
the pores in your mouth there's another
condition called uremic Frost where your
sweat glands are eliminating uric acid
crystals and now it's coming out to the
skin so you'll see this kind of like a
white frost on your skin that is a
really specific indicator that there's a
kidney problem especially with protein
metabolism all right and then the last
one is a loss of appetite and that
probably goes along with you know the
metallic taste in your mouth and the
nauseousness but just because you lose
your appetite doesn't mean that it's a
problem like if you go on the ketogenic
diet where you're doing fasting you're
going to lose your appetite as well but
if you have this sudden loss of appetite
uh you might want to get your kidneys
checked so there's various stages of
kidney damage you have one through five
and when you get to five the only
solution is either a kidney transplant
and or you're on dialysis
I mean you're talking many times a week
going to this Clinic you're spending
hours there getting your kidney filtered
it's devastating and the current medical
treatment for kidney disease
is that they're basically managing
certain things because they use
medication and medications are toxic so
the more medication that you give the
kidney or even the liver the worse the
problem is so there's not a really good
solution medically for advanced kidney
disease it's just all about managing so
they're going to manage blood pressure
they're going to manage your diabetes
and your diabetic symptoms they will
probably give you a medication for edema
or swelling like Hydrochlorothiazide
which is a blood thinner and if you're
type 2 diabetic you're probably going to
be on Metformin and if you have high
blood pressure they probably will give
you like an Ace inhibitor uh something
like that now since there are multiple
causes of kidney problems you would want
to address the underlying cause so if it
is diabetes that's the area you need to
focus in on not the symptom of a kidney
problem if your kidney problem is coming
from an infection of course you're going
to focus on that but I want to give you
some natural alternatives to certain
medications you're taking of course
check with your doctor before
implementing this but let's first start
with high blood pressure from a
nutritional standpoint the two things
that are usually always deficient are
number one potassium and number two
vitamin D so by taking potassium and
vitamin D you can many times lower blood
pressure now that brings up the topic of
potassium you probably have been told
that that potassium is dangerous for the
kidney so people tend to avoid it
because if you get high levels of
potassium called hyperkalemia then
there's a risk of arrhythmia problems
and all sorts of other heart problems
now check out this interesting research
paper that talks about potassium and
chronic kidney disease it says potassium
often has a negative connotation in
Nephrology as patients with chronic
kidney disease are prone to develop
hyperkalemia that's that high potassium
yet emerging data indicate that dietary
potassium may be beneficial for patients
with chronic kidney disease Studies have
shown that a higher urinary potassium
excretion is associated with low blood
pressure and lower cardiovascular risk
as well as better kidney outcomes
moreover increasing dietary potassium in
Tech can exert blood pressure
independent effects on the kidney by
relieving the deleterious effects of a
low potassium diet
inflammation oxidative stress and
fibrosis so when you're low in potassium
you get more inflammation you get more
oxidative stress and you get more
fibrosis the three things you don't want
when you have kidney problems so there
are a lot more studies that talks about
potassium being protective on the kidney
so sometimes when people hear things out
of context like if you have stage five
kidney disease then of course you know
you can't regulate potassium so that's
going to be toxic but what if you have
stage four or stage three or stage two
so some people take this idea that it's
bad for end-stage kidney disease and say
it's bad for any type of kidney problem
which is absolutely not true I mean
phosphorus is very very damaging to the
kidney if your stay H5 so should we also
avoid anything with phosphorus even if
our kidneys are not that bad yet you see
consuming potassium as a supplement or
electrolyte powder or consuming foods
high in potassium won't cause kidney
problems they will not cause
hyperkalemia which is high potassium in
the blood because your kidneys if
they're healthy or if they're working
somewhat can regulate that and get rid
of any excesses that you have the other
piece of the puzzle is this
our bodies require tremendous amounts of
potassium even to maintain a healthy
body out of all the different nutrients
there are potassium is needed in the
highest amounts like 4 700 milligrams
every single day so if you're starting
to get some symptoms with the kidney and
you start cutting back potassium what's
going to happen is you may have more
inflammation more oxidative stress more
fibrosis and you're going to have higher
amounts of sodium because potassium
sodium work together and potassium can
help alter the pH of your body so your
body's not too acid or too far on the pH
scale let's just touch on ph per second
so we have this pH scale right this acid
alkaline scale right in the middle of
the scale is seven which is neutral
anything above seven is more alkaline
anything below seven is more acidic this
scale goes from 0 to 14 and it just so
happens that the urine has the highest
or widest range of ph's it can be from
4.5 all the way up to eight versus other
fluids in the body have a much more
narrow range especially with your blood
which should be slightly alkaline so one
of the big purposes of the urine is to
ensure that the blood pH stays at that
real narrow range 7.4 so your kidneys
are constantly dumping off certain
things to adjust this pH they'll lose
like bicarbonates or calcium which are
alkalizing agents or they'll dump acids
to help balance this pH so typically the
urine should be slightly acidic but if
it's strongly acidic let's say it stays
at a five there are certain indicators
that you could have potential kidney
problems down the road but there's some
mixed studies on that topic but let me
just go through a couple things with ph
so if someone's a diabetic they're
typically going to have more acidic
urine than someone that's not a diabetic
especially if they forget to take the
medication and there's this out of range
blood sugar situation now on the flip
side if you have a UTI urinary tract
infection your urine will tend to be
alkaline what's happening there is you
have this bacteria which is making more
ammonia which happens to be very
alkaline it's not acid now when you're
dehydrated you tend to have more acidic
urine and the more chronic renal failure
you have
actually the more alkaline the urine is
going to be which is you would think
it'd be more acidic but it's going to be
more alkaline now during times of
starvation your urine is going to be
very acid and also when you do fasting
your urine is going to be more acid
because you're burning up your fat
releasing ketones which are acidic so
you can have something really bad like
starvation or something really good
fasting and have an acidic urine so
about having an acidic urine you can't
really tell what's going on it's just
one of the clues that you need to
associate with a lot of other clothes
like a history when someone typically
consumes a very heavy meat diet with
nothing no vegetables to alkalize that
they'll tend to be more acidic versus
someone who pretty much just eats
vegetables and doesn't have any animal
protein they'll be more alkaline and as
far as kidney stones go
your pH could be either alkaline or
acidic because there are different Stone
formations that can occur like for
example uric acid stones or even calcium
oxalate stones form more in an acidic
urine or calcium phosphate Stones occur
when you have an alkaline pH I'm just
trying to increase your knowledge on ph
because you can't just automatically
like say well I'm going to change my pH
to help my kidneys you have to really
understand what's going on behind the
scenes I mean I'll give you an example
someone bought one of those machines
that alkalize water right and so they
were drinking this water which was
artificially alkalized and I checked
their urine pH in my clinic and their pH
was a nine like that's like extremely
alkaline and typically you think that's
a healthy thing but you're artificially
changing the pH of the water without
really understanding um what's going on
in the rest of the body if you eat
healthy and you become healthy
your pH will go to exactly what your
body needs to handle whatever but to
force your body into one pH isn't always
a good thing but let's say for example
you don't have stage five let's say you
have some kidney problems and your pH is
pretty acid there are things you can do
potassium is one thing you can add
especially if you're prone to those
kidney stones the most common ones being
calcium oxalates which develop in an
acid environment and if you have gout
and you have these uric acid crystals by
alkalizing the body with potassium you
can actually improve the symptoms and I
like potassium because it also can
protect the kidney now there's also
baking soda you can take a little bit of
that to help protect the kidney
especially if there's like a high blood
pressure situation and your pH is to
acid But realize that baking soda is
high in sodium okay so so sodium is one
of those things that they're telling you
to avoid because of the blood pressure
problem but if you have enough potassium
there to counter that you should be okay
now I started to talk about some
alternatives for high blood pressure
medication like potassium and then
vitamin D right well there's other
things as well garlic is a natural ACE
inhibitor but without the side effects
lion's mane mushroom is another natural
ACE inhibitor and pycnogenol is also a
natural ACE inhibitor when we get to
diabetes
cinnamon is a potent spice that can help
not just bring down your blood sugars
but your insulin is well people who have
diabetes who take cinnamon need a little
less medication because it helps your
blood sugars apple cider vinegar is
another great way to help regulate blood
sugars and going on keto intermittent
fasting could ultimately correct type 2
diabetes because what is diabetes too
much sugar in your bloodstream what is
keto and I have the reduction of
carbohydrates in the diet so that's kind
of a no-brainer
now when we get to edema whether it's
around your eyes or in your ankles
potassium is a natural diuretic because
it can help push out the fluid and it
counters the sodium and the water
retention problem but as you can see
potassium keeps coming up as a good
thing as a kidney protector for edema
and even high blood pressure which is
the exact opposite thing that people
generally think now one of the things
about going on the ketogenic diet and
doing intermittent fasting especially
together is that you dump a lot of
excess fluid on average about 13 pounds
of fluid within the first one to two
weeks because there's no need to hold or
store that much stored sugar called
glycogen anymore and so when the body
dumps the stored sugar it also dumps the
water that's connected to that sugar and
lastly there's a really great Indian
herb for chronic kidney disease as well
as fluid retention and edema and that
herb is called punanaba and lastly one
of the most important preventative
things you can do for kidney problems is
getting on the right diet and I'm
talking about that healthy version of
Keto with intermittent fasting and I put
the best video I have that will walk you
through step by step how to do it
correctly right here